on en vient à ces images une trentaine
de réservistes dont un tiers de femmes
est essentiellement des étudiants ont
prêté serment lors d'une audience au
tribunal de grande instance de tours
après avoir suivi une formation de 4
semaines tire encore séance de sport
désormais tous sont dépositaires de
l'autorité publique droiture dignité
respect de la loi ces termes se sont
invitées à plusieurs reprises ce matin
suite aux évènements tragiques que nous
avons connu il ya eu effectivement un
acte de volontariat une sorte de service
citoyen et ces jeunes se sont rapprochés
de la gendarmerie pour pouvoir faire
j'allais dire un service qui correspond
à une aide à l'heure actuelle à la
société aux citoyens justement non très
bons amis m'ont parlé souvent j'ai voulu
aussi mois fin j'étais très sportive la
loi j'aimais beaucoup sa fin je
m'intéressais beaucoup à la loi donc
j'ai voulu aller dans la gendarmerie la
suite à des des témoignages qu'on avait
au lycée justement à la base aérienne à
trous noirs on a eu des réunions et puis
on se dit mon engagement va pourquoi pas
essayer et puis une fois là bas oui
c'est un déclic c'est je me suis dit je
veux faire ça plus tard